welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in spider-man into the spider verse
two released a teaser revealing the
release date for its sequel April 8th
2022 if the world is still even here
it's got a splashy art design that you
just know the YouTube psychos like me
are gonna use to predict the whole vamp
why are these merely simple glitches the
way the animation of the first into the
spider verse often was nope because
those weren't Lich's either they were
evidence of collisions remove its
fighting verses into this one and going
by the color palette an animation style
of each glitch there are definitely some
clues for which Spidey's we might see in
the next film I'm gonna break down
everything that I found and spoiler
warning in case they get anything to
write in that ruins your light let us
overanalyze the crap out of this tweet
with another new rockstars tweeter
brother
okay the teaser opens on these simple
red spray paint on black background the
logo and colors of Miles Morales in the
first into the spider verse film when he
used his artistry to design a new look
for himself in the third act then
shortly after the year is revealed the
next interesting glitch in versus those
colors which you could interpret as a
nod to mr. negative
who has played a big role in recent ps4
games but this blue on white color
scheme also kind of reflects the ghost
spider spirit spider skin from the ps4
game next mouse's logo gets highlighted
with a dark yellow which could be a nod
to the 1990s animated spider-man series
which use similar colors for its logo
now remember the first end of the spider
verse ended with a post-credits scene
showing spider-man 2099 Miguel O'Hara
voiced by Oscar Isaac acquiring a device
that allowed him to jump across
realities throughout the spider verse
ending with him in a pointy match with a
1960s animated Spider Man how dare you
point at me who you were pointing first
rude to point you're being very rude
Elle's device
Plus that moment at the end of end of
the spider verse would spider-gwen
portaling into chat with Miles suggests
that the rift between dimensions across
the spider verse is still open and it
could cause these realities to bleed
into each other including the 1960s and
1990s animated iterations Tom Holland
even revealed that there was a
discussion about having him make a
live-action cameo in a purse movie and
Lord and Miller said they wanted to try
to get Tobey Maguire to cameo has this
Spider Man as well so in total I counted
at least 25 different Lich's in this
teaser which just should indicate to us
a potentially infinite number of
sever's and cameos and let's keep going
there's a quick flash of miles logo
illuminated in neon which I'm wondering
could be a nod to the penny part or
super in the first film which lit up in
different ways
shortly after there's a softer edge logo
with red pink white and black which is
roughly the color palette of the Cyndi
moon silk character then one frame after
that the logo switches to become a hard
edge red and yellow which is the same
design style of the logo for the 1978
Japanese spider-man TV series next
there's this light blue logo outlined in
red and black to me this reflects the
color palette of spider-man's secret war
suit next are two very interesting logos
that I can't identify at the moment
there's a pink bubbly font one and then
a pale orange seafoam green background
in which the logo cuts into it like a
stencil both have these two dimensional
quality like they were cut and pasted
from one surface onto another maybe like
a scrapbook and let me know if you can
ID these then there's a flash of this
white and gray logo I was thinking this
could be a nod to spider-man noir but
there's obviously something more to this
one with all the blue pattern inlay but
a bit later there's a flash of yellow
with a white star multicolored lightning
bolts pretty sure this is a nod to
spider-ham Peter porker while his blast
effects reflecting the Looney Tunes
style animation of his world and then
there's this mysterious one it's colored
and green and purple and magenta covered
in these white hash marks and a few
loose ends that dangle and loop to me
these kind of look like stitch marks
like this logo was knitted no no maybe
we'll see a spider Aunt May the next
logo is a real nasty one it's red and
black covered in scratches bloody super
violent some are saying this evokes
carnage whom we know will be a villain
in the next live-action venom story but
I think we wouldn't see carnage and the
animated spider-verse sequel without
first seeing venom maybe we'll get both
then there's this quick flash to a logo
in green white pink and black obviously
this is a nod to spider Gwen those are
her colors the green for her ballet
shoes along with Miles Morales Gwen
Stacy is the one character confirmed for
the sequel with Hailee Steinfeld
reprising voice now right after
spider-gwen there's another quick flash
to a logo in red and black on a yellow
surface some are describing this as a
color scheme for Spider Woman Jessica
drew could see that but it's also worth
noting that background is some office
surface like a legal envelope or a
drawer you can see a paper clips and
staples perhaps this could point to the
newspaper
office of the Daily Bugle and its
employees like Betty Brant Jay jonah
Jameson Eddie Brock next the logo
appears on a light blue background which
matches the color palette a Ben Riley
suit from the Clone Saga and as all of
the logos flash on the screen of
different combinations one last color
combination that stands out to me is the
red on navy blue the color palette
associated with spider-man 2099 Miguel
O'Hara the futuristic spider-man from
the post-credits scene who seems to be
the key to all of this universe swapping
now what's the point to all these spider
things existing in one story together
other than tube top Avengers endgame as
the biggest crossover boon to the motor
coup story or really to top the film
that actually holds that title Who
Framed Roger Rabbit well the theory that
I'm most excited about is that the next
film could be an adaptation of the
spider get an event from the
spider-verse comics in this event the
inheritors they're energy vampires who
travel the multiverse to suck out the
energy of the spider individuals they've
broken out of their radioactive universe
prison that they were trapped in part
one of the story now all the spider
heroes have to assemble a spider army to
stop them using dimensional wristwatches
just like the one Miguel O'Hara
introduced in the post-credits scene
spider Geddon involves a number of
spider individuals that I mentioned in
this breakdown belong with spider u.k
spider Punk spider Indias Scarlet Spider
and others a lot of deaths it's
heartbreaking but now that the
multiverse has been ripped wide open
it's gonna require a multi-dimensional
and comic book II story to heighten what
we got in the first into the spider
verse film and since they're giving
themselves several years to work on this
it is clear they aren't rushing
themselves they are likely planning
something with a lot of dots but which
spider-man are you most excited to see
in the sequel comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at EA boss follow new rock stars
on social media at rockstars
and subscribe in new york stars on
youtube for everything you love thank
you for watching now if you'll excuse me
Tom Holland just sneezed and I got a
breakdown it's not
[Music]